according to your vice interview
you know you were very outspoken that
there definitely needs to be
prison reform right and uh
the steps that are and you were actually
vocal about how blacks were
in the system sort of targeted
judicially unfairly so here's
here's the problem in in this not only
not only am i an advocate under
president trump
he signed the first step act i was
pretty instrumental in getting getting
that
passed i was actually in the oval office
with him when he signed the bill
and that was to basically create
incentives
good time incentives for inmates in
federal prison
so they they would get out sooner
without keeping them locked away forever
and a bunch of other things but to to go
to your question
here's my problem with the system you
take
areas like let's take baltimore for
example
the dea goes in and they do these stings
right where they're gonna lock up
really bad guys guys are engaged in
violence guys are bad guys
i have no problem with going after the
bad guys the really bad guys if they're
authentically you know the villains
right
but when you have young kids today 18 19
17 years old
they go out there buying dime bags of
cocaine right
and they get caught up in these
conspiracies with these other bad guys
well guess what they get charged with
the same amount of weight
that the bad guy did if the guy's doing
two kilos a week
and you went out and bought three dime
bags in a week and they
saw you when they witnessed it and they
called you
for those three buys you get you get
charged
with the two kilos how's that even
possible well that's like what's that
what's the logic in that like if there
is
there is no logic okay there is no logic
and that's my argument
so what you do is you then take that
that young kid
who had no prior record you lock him up
and you basically say look you're
looking at life
because that two kilos that gets you
life you're looking at life
take a plea for 10 years and your
defense
your your defense lawyer most of them
are you know provided by the courts
he says you got to take the deal take
the deal you'll be fine
10 years you're you're not doing life
ten years you're eighteen you'll be
honest with me
you'll be out when you're 26. just take
the deal okay great
you you sign a plea for ten years
okay you do eight okay
you had no criminal record you had no
criminal background
you're not a bad kid but guess what we
did
we took you and we put you into a system
that's full of monsters right yeah what
is prison
prison is a training ground for thuggery
criminality
you learn how to steal cheat lie
it's like a business school for thugs
it's it's a business school for thugs
and violence right you need to survive
you need to learn how to fight you get
into a verbal altercation
and you know the end of that is usually
somebody getting knifed
pummeled cut um that's the bottom line
that's what we did we took that that 18
year old kid
who had no violence no problems we put
him into the system
and then at 26 we sent him home and
legislators in washington have sat
around
in circle jerks for the past 30 years
they can't figure out why the recidivism
rate isn't dropping
what's this word recidivism revisiting
jail yeah right gotcha
so the recidivism rate isn't dropping
because these guys have no choice but to
revert to crime
they come out after 26 years and i had
kids
in prison that i was teaching classes to
and i would say
you know you got to get your ged you
gotta you got to try to get some college
when you get out
and they would look at me and they'd say
commission i'm black
i'm a convicted felon i'm not going to
be able to get a job
that ged is not going to help me and
here's the sad thing
for the most part the right they're
right they're right well
the question for you because when you
have a felony on your record you're
[ __ ]
no you're [ __ ] yeah and and they know
it
right and they know so it's like all
right what's the point of getting the
ged the high school degree because once
i'm a felon
that's going to follow me for life any
any job they ask you have you ever been
convicted of a felony
yes [ __ ] that candidate i mean that
basically happens that's
exactly what happens nobody nobody gets
it nobody
you know everybody talks a good game in
the in the legislators you know
oh we're you know we want to do this we
want to do this
you know what you know getting that
first step act signed
by president trump it was a major
headache if it wasn't for jared kushner
and
in a whole cadre of people around him
that
fought like hell with these legislators
that thing would have never got signed
never and it's still not enough it's far
from enough but obama was doing stuff
too and i know you're not
a fan of obama but i know but i worked i
was i worked with the obama
administration trying to get it done
trying to get it done i i spent f i was
in the white house physically
four or five times during the obama
administration
wow trying to get it done trying to get
these guys to work together
and you know listen i am i am uh
these days i think everybody and you
know for the exception of maybe
five people out of all of congress
you know the senators the congressmen
they're all full of [ __ ]
you know they they tell you one thing
privately
they you know oh it's the right thing to
do you're right you're 100
right you're right you're right you're
right you're right you're right and they
walk out the door
they stand up at a press conference and
they say well we're not sure
we don't know we'll have to look at it
you know there are issues like politics
they have to kind of defend their
position their political parties
they not only defend their position but
they're basically
you know some guy didn't sign off on a
bill that this guy
wants well it's it's revenge time so now
i'm going to not i'm not going to sign
his [ __ ] because
he didn't sign mine so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you